hey how's it going how are you doing i'm
carlos with 80 candidates
what's happening congratulations on this
yeah there are people that said it
couldn't be done man and you guys did it
oh my gosh um it was
it's it's really surreal to have so many
people
anticipate one thing that that you are a
part of
there's been a lot of pressure
to get to this stage and really hats off
to everybody involved yeah it's uh the
story is legendary neil is obviously
legendary
what was it specifically about this that
made you go i have to be a part of this
well you know a lot of things where do i
begin now you you you
you everything you put in every as an
actor every film or project i've ever
done i put in the same amount of work
but you know some films uh go to
festivals and they're not seen
i've done a show with netflix before
and i saw
how far narcos reached people
uh and i knew about the comic and i knew
that the corinthian was really
just one of the
more satisfying characters i guess you
could say or i would say in the comic um
so all those things coming together
bottlenecking
i knew that um it would it would be
something is getting a roll like this
when you play this character does it
feel sort of like i've never done it but
i can equate it to like getting to
actually spend like getting to really
stretch your legs and do what you really
want to do out there
well i mean
acting is an amazing
process where you you do get to perform
something you've never been able to do
or imagine you can do
being on set with all these great actors
and having this material and these sets
uh it's it's it's it's every you know
kid's dream to uh to be able to
play uh make believe at the highest
level
[Laughter]
is there anything that neil said to you
or to the cast at the beginning of
production that kind of set the course
for you guys
no you know i didn't want to get my feet
our hands dirty in that way of saying is
there anything that i must do that will
make you happy sir
um i i knew that alan heinberg and david
goyer
uh and our wonderful you know people
that you guys will never meet they put
so much time and effort into all this
that
i know that what they've given me to
perform is
the cream of the crop so
it's really just honoring the material
showing up and uh bringing your
creativity to the table what do people
have to look forward to when they meet
you on screen for the first time
i think he's a rascal that you'll
find yourself wondering why do i like
this guy
um
that's my hope we'll see
all right man thank you so much for the
time congrats thanks cheers